you want to really know how to ruin a
party just tell everyone you're gonna
die tomorrow
i'm dying jane we heard you i'm dying i
heard you
she dies tomorrow as the latest in a
long string of digital horror releases
coming out due to covid19
and i guess it's kind of fitting because
the film asks the question
what if death were contagious i mean
it's right here in the tagline
in this video we'll be taking a look at
all the hidden details as well as
explaining its cryptic ending
but before we get into it make sure to
like and subscribe cause
you know i might die tomorrow the film
begins on an extreme close-up of a
character named amy
i'm hesitant to call her the main
character because the film really
doesn't have a main character
instead we follow the infected people
infected by an idea that they're going
to die tomorrow
so in a way i guess you could say the
main character is
death damn right we are constantly
following it as it moves from one
character to the next
and what we're seeing here in this first
shot is a scene that doesn't happen
until near the end of the movie amy and
her partner craig go on a bit of a
romantic getaway ordering some pizza
only for the pizza delivery guy to pass
on the infection to craig and how is
this passed on
well if you hear someone say they think
they're gonna die tomorrow
boom you think you're gonna die tomorrow
in the next shot we see how the
infection takes over craig as he
throws [ __ ] around the room saying
things like it's over there's no
tomorrow and that he's not crazy but we
wake up the next day following amy with
craig nowhere to be found we know it's
the next day because of the same pizza
box laying on the floor next to her
but what we don't know is that craig is
dead remember that opening eye shot well
that's taken from this scene later on in
the film where amy says the same exact
lines she does at the beginning of the
film now it's never explained in the
film whether he killed himself or if she
killed him but my guess is that he shot
himself with this gun here
and she passed out on the couch herself
now infected
this is where the story really begins
amy ventures back to her home and calls
her friend
jane who knows all about her past as a
recovering addict she may even be like
an a support friend it's here amy does
some really weird [ __ ] like
rub herself on the walls the floorboards
a piece of wood
and ventures into the forest to touch
the fallen leaves and what do all these
things have in common
they're all dead hell when jane comes up
to check on her she's drinking wine and
blowing dead leaves with a leaf blower
she even turns on the bug zapper to
watch the bugs die
amy also has an obsession of playing
mozart's lacrimosa
over and over again a piece of music
which was meant as a requiem to
commemorate the death of a renowned
austrian count's wife coincidentally
mozart died while composing this piece
and mozart's widow claimed mozart went a
little crazy and believed he was writing
the requiem for his
own funeral so this is definitely a
fitting piece for this movie amy then
does some rather odd internet searches
including cremation urns and leather
jackets
that's because she believes she's going
to die tomorrow and she wants to be
turned into a leather jacket
i was thinking
i could be made into a leather jacket
this is followed by a flashback with her
and craig where he asks her if she has
any regrets and we learned that amy had
an abortion when she was 22. this
explains the
baby wailing noises amy hears the night
before she's to die
amy is haunted by the decision to
terminate her child
throughout the film we also see the
characters experience flashes of blue
red purple and green they kind of
resemble christmas lights and there's
even a shot near the end
where amy walks past an ornamented
christmas tree in a leather working shop
which i don't think is just a
coincidence
christmas is an event that signifies
birth so to have it juxtaposed here in
the film
a film all about death is rather
interesting
we also get a quick shot of her
seemingly having an orgasm while wearing
this party dress
my interpretation is that she is
reliving the night she got pregnant
there are even these super quick shots
which i had to freeze frame of what
appears to be
a beating heart something that would
have stopped when she terminated the
baby the next part of the film focuses
on jane who now too
is infected she puts on the same mozart
song that amy was listening to as she
conducts
research with a microscope now we never
really know what she's looking into
is it blood or some other substance but
according to a woman named susan who
we'll meet in a bit
jane looks into her microscope to quote
discover the universe now jane can't
shake the feeling that she's going to
die
so she interrupts her sister-in-law's
birthday party in her pajamas to let
them know it's going to happen there are
some cool easter eggs here like framed
paintings of jane's microscopic findings
and a yield sign that says you are alive
it's also ironic that a woman who thinks
she's going to die
tells people so at a birthday party and
what follows is just
truly morbid all the guests are now
infected and believe
they are also going to die so this guy
named brian goes with his girlfriend
tilly and takes his dad who suffered a
stroke
off of life support then over his dead
father's body tilly tells brian she
wanted to break up with him for the past
6 months
they don't care anymore everyone is
brutally honest they're gonna die
tomorrow so
why not be susan and jane's brother
jason go into their daughter's room and
tell her that they're going to die
you know just a fun little thing to tell
your child now it's heavily implied that
jason
and susan killed their kid we see susan
kiss her daughter in the morning
unsure if she's sleeping or dead and
jason later asks susan if she feels bad
about what they did
implying the murder of their child and
the infection continues to spread
jane visits a doctor and infects him amy
goes dune buggying something she wanted
to do before she died
and infects the owner fun fact the dune
buggy owner is played by adam wingard
who directed horror films like you're
next
and the new blair witch jane arrives
back home and goes back to her research
talking to her samples saying she missed
them it's really weird but
maybe not as weird as jane waking up the
next morning and entering a random house
bleeding from a huge cut
and the other two women there don't see
anything unusual about it they also
proclaim that they
are dying too so jane goes into the pool
and oh god that's gonna need to be
cleaned a particular note here is one of
the characters using
ash to create a painting as symbol of
death
ash used to create art yet another
example of this balance of life and
death this film portrays and this scene
seems to indicate that this
infection has spread like crazy one of
the girls remarks how on earth could
someone be mowing their lawn right now
obviously not something someone would do
if this was their last day on earth
so it begs the question how far has this
thing spread
and there's also this really interesting
shot where you can make out a lens flare
that kind of looks like one of jane's
samples under the microscope we
like jane are observing these characters
through the lens of
film just like jane observed her
examples through the lens of a
microscope amy appears to get her wish
of becoming a leather jacket yes i know
just saying that sounds really weird
when she asked a leatherworker about
what she would need to do to bring in
her own mammal to be skinned
aka herself you have to bring in the
skin as soon as possible
and the final shot of the movie finds
amy all alone in the middle of a
deserted wasteland going back and forth
saying lines
i'm okay and i'm not ready these are the
same lines craig said
shortly before he died she also starts
to hum just like the doctor asked jane
to do when she visited him but that line
i'm not okay also makes an appearance
earlier in the film when jane confronts
amy about her relapse
it's not okay
it just is and perhaps that's what the
film is saying about
death it's inevitable it just is a way
of life
some are okay with it and some aren't
but the constant remains that it will
happen this last shot of amy leaves us
wondering what will happen to her
but does it really matter whether it's
today or tomorrow she will
die and if what happened to the other
characters are any indication she'll
likely be on the way out
whether she's ready or not thanks for
watching everyone please make sure to
like and subscribe and leave me a
comment on what you thought of she dies
tomorrow
you can also follow me on twitter at
thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much